before you all met Michael Jackson what
did he mean to you so I first became
aware of Michael Jackson when I was
about two and I saw the making of
thriller and just instantly became
obsessed with it and wanted to watch it
all day every day and started doing the
dance moves as soon as I could you know
walk properly and and then quickly my
walls were plastered with you know
images of Michael and he was just this
absolutely incredible otherworldly
figure to me that I wanted to be just
like and I dressed like him every day
and did my hair and had my hair permed
to look like him and you know all that
stuff I wasn't a huge fan before I met
him
and then when I got the commercial they
they Dempsey yeah the Pepsi commercial
they did this thing where they would say
every day that Michaels going to show up
but it was always his stand-in so
actually in the commercial when you see
me meet him is actually my first time
seeing him and you know at that point I
was pretty excited and so was was
otherworldly I guess yeah
yeah that was yeah it was one thing to
meet him the first time when I was five
and I ended up dancing with him in his
show he asked me to dance with him in
the show the next night and you know
that was incredible and we had a
two-hour hangout the next day with my
mother in his hotel room that was a
whole nother level then we didn't have
any contact for a couple of years and
then I met him again when I was seven
and this is when be you know so-called
friendship began here I was this little
boy from Australia who I was so enamored
by him so in love with him such a huge
fan and now within the first day or so
he's telling me that we were brought
together by God you know that we
we're meant to be together that you
wanted to be my friend you know and he
thought I was amazing he thought I was
so talented and he thought I was so
sweet and and he wanted to spend all of
his time with me so this feeling of
being you know the chosen one out of all
the kids in the world you had to feel
very special about that way absolutely
yeah yeah for you James
yeah he's just quickly you know very
likeable and engaging and gives you
focused attention and you know he's
disarming he's he's a charming guy I
mean so you instantly you feel very
comfortable with him so that sort of
bond and and friendship develops quickly
and then he does start saying you're
talented you're special and him you know
the first night or so teaching me a
moonwalk and you know all these things
that had been so surreal and from
another planet on TV were now a part of
my life and Michael Jackson was my best
friend as he said you know he told you
he would call you his best friend yeah
yeah within the first you know day or so
mm-hmm did you feel like the best friend
to James oh for sure it was very much
you and him sort of against the world
kind of feeling so yeah you were very
much best friends did you two know each
other as children did you two were you
aware of each other as children I had
seen the Pepsi commercial yeah that he
was in so I remember even seeing that
commercial was like that that could be
me or that should be me you know I wish
that was me but the only time I ever
remember meeting James or a couple times
was later when I was about nine on the
music video of Jam Michaels jam music
video which I danced in and James was
there with Michael as well and we met
then and hung out a little bit mm-hmm
how do you go from Michael Jackson is an
idol we're friends - now that friendship
changes - what how and when did it
change so you know the intense
friendship
with Michael started when I was about 7
over the next two years I still lived in
Australia and Michael would bring me out
multiple times through those two years
to spend time with him so when we met
the second time when I was 7 years old
Michael invited us to Neverland that
weekend I think it was a Friday that we
that we met initially talked about
another planet I mean this was just the
most magical thing I'd ever seen
flowers and statues and lights and trees
just saris wheel yeah just incredible
and that first night you know Michael he
just kind of took us on a little bit of
a tour and he said to me and my sister
you know you can you can stay in one of
the guest rooms or you can stay in here
with me if you want my reaction was of
course I want to stay with you
and I think we all just kind of knocked
out at some point
nothing particular happened that night
we had one more night that way and then
the plan was the monday.the myself and
my family we're gonna leave and go on
another kind of vacation to the Grand
Canyon I was devastated to leave Michael
Michael was devastated for me to leave
he actually sobbed in front of me say
you got to stay so I got to stay and so
it was just Michael and I Neverland for
the next week and and your parents
allowed that my parents about that yeah
and then with in either the first or
second night of Michael and I being
alone at Neverland the night started
changing and one of the ways I remember
it starting is you know Michael just
sort of starting to touch my legs and
touch my crotch over my pants and then
it kind of kept progressing from there
he would grab my hand and have him love
me do the same thing to to you know his
crotch over his pants and then
it progressed to him performing oral sex
on me him showing me how to perform oral
sex on him and showing me how to French
kiss
squeeze his nipples did you know what
was happening did you think that that
was an appropriate did it scare you did
you think it was wrong
a couple of days prior to the abuse
starting Michael had already started
being he started touching me just in the
sense of like Pande on my leg lots of
hugs kissing my forehead rubbing my
hands so there had been this kind of
development of physical closeness that
was happening already that felt like a
father you know just felt amazing
and strangely now for me looking back at
it when it went to the next furthest
extreme of sexual contact something
about it felt like just the next step
and really quickly as Michael started
doing these sexual acts he started
talking to me about you know God brought
us together we love each other and this
is how we love each other we love each
other and this is how we show each other
our love and then right away the next
part of the dialogue was but if anybody
else ever found out about any of this
you and I would go to jail for the rest
of our lives and we'd be pulled apart
our lives would be over our careers
would be over we can't let that happen
we've got so much to do together we've
got to rule the world together were you
frightened by the actions or his words I
was not frightened by the action you
were not you do not think this is creepy
don't touch me
this is wrong you didn't think any of
that no I didn't think
that it was out of all the kids in the
world right here I am and Michael shows
me and he also told me that you know
I've never done this with anybody else
yeah yeah James you're nodding an
agreement to what he's saying yeah well
there's a conversation tell me what
happened to you is you're listening to
what Wade is saying it clearly seems to
resonate with you yeah I mean that's all
the same you know he did the same thing
to me as well he introduced me to
masturbation and then then you start
kissing and I'm on tour so we're
together 24/7 and it's happening over a
period of time and then you're kissing
and he said I taught him out of French
kiss
and then it moves on to oral sex it's
like can I kiss it that kind of thing
that's what it starts with I'm
frightened or thinking this is weird or
wrong no no it's in the context of uh
loving close relationships a special
friends yeah there's no alarm bells
going off in your head or or any
thoughts like that really it's just I
love this person and and we're trying to
make each other happy and he said I was
this first but even as a kid you don't
even know what that means you know you
don't even question it further than that
yeah you don't say your first one first
what right yeah as an adult you'd think
that but as a kid you're just like
that's great and you know you're special
and you know as well as you know we are
not gay we just love each other and this
is how you show your love he would say
to you we're not gay yeah do you even
know what that meant is a little kid
actually
yeah I mean as soon as the abuse started
I had this question of does this mean
I'm gay now that the abuse is when you
started on tour where did these things
happen and where are the adults who were
supposed to be watching you right so for
me in the beginning you know there was
those first couple nights in the bedroom
with my sister once she was out of the
picture was when things changed right
and my parents were now and my
grandparents left for that next week and
Neverland
so for that first week of abuse they
were in another you know part of
California and what about Michaels staff
the staffer everywhere mmm
you know not in the room his abuse is
happening but before and after and
around and there's maids and there's
cooks and there's security guards
everywhere and none of them appear to be
concerned that you're staying in the
room with him no not that I witnessed
uh-huh James where were the adults so
when you're there there's nobody else
there and on tour
my mom would stay in a different room
and I was with in Michael's room the
whole time at Neverland I think he kept
us away or kept me away from the maids
so you know when they come around you
kind of try to go away and I was that
was just on that point that was always
the thing that I remember from the
beginning Michael always saying do not
talk to any other staff for sure not
allowed to have friendships and talk
about anything we say anything we do
yeah and even untoward to go after that
he if somebody else talked to you he
would notice and then he questioned you
what did they say
what do they want and he makes you
fearful of talking to other people
and there's you know when you're on tour
everybody's wanting to talk to you and
you know ask you questions but at what
point did you all start to think that
this is wrong was or was there ever a
point that you started thinking this is
wrong
well the abuse was going on so the abuse
for me went from age 7 to 14 years old I
do remember when I was about 11 or 12 as
I would see him less frequently and then
when I would see him it was still just
kind of back to the old business right
as soon as possible as soon as we could
get into a private space he wanted to do
all the sexual stuff again
I remember feeling around 12:00 starting
to be a little more uncomfortable about
that and sometimes maybe trying to
change the subject or you know distract
but then but then having a fear that if
I don't do this
I'm already feeling like I'm not a
favorite of Michael's anymore and if I
don't do this what's gonna happen what's
gonna happen to our friendship
yeah yeah you were worried about losing
the friend yeah so is it feeling like
you need to continue this because you
wanted to just still be friends with
them the public in general thinks it's
violent that it's very painful that it
hurts and that it's very scary but what
you're describing is totally the
opposite of that right yeah that was the
thing is that the way Michael approached
the abuse the sexual activity with me
was always extremely tender and again
began with hugs and embraces and kisses
on the head and then just kept expanding
in that direction but to a much
obviously much more twisted place but
yeah there was never I mean you didn't
beat me he didn't you know he'd never
said mean things to me it was all we
love each other
it's all tender and you feel special
yeah you all both tell a very
descriptive story about you know sexual
activity was Michael Jackson he went to
trial in 2005 he called on both of you
to testify on his behalf
and Wade you did you got on the stand
and you testified in his behalf and
vehemently denied that any sexual
activity had taken place yes why did you
do that yeah well you know the training
Michaels training of me to testify began
the first night that he started abusing
me in the sense that as I told you you
know that right away after the first
kind of experience of sexual abuse he
started telling me that if anybody of
anybody else ever finds out we'll both
go to jail both of our lives will be
over
we can't tell other people this is what
Michael would say because other people
are ignorant they just wouldn't
understand that this is how we show our
love right well why did you want to
protect him you loved him I loved him
and the thought of him going to jail
was an unfathomable thought for me that
would just just terrified me and so I
was gonna do anything I could do to
protect my friend you know they credit
your testimony in part for Michaels
acquittal you were called really a star
witness you you withstood a blistering
cross-examination on some level do you
feel guilty about that now because
another person who was making
allegations Michael Jackson was
acquitted of what he was accused of
doing to him does that do you think
about that or did you think about him
yeah I do think about that I have and I
do gosh I wish it was different you know
I wish that I was ready I wish that I
could have helped Gavin Arvizo receive
some justice and some validation for
what happened to him that was just like
what happened to me and just like what
happened to James and I wish that I
could have played a role in at that
point
stopping Michael from abusing however
many other kids he did after that yeah
you're both admitting to us that you did
lie in the past the Jackson family and
Jackson fans as you know or adamantly
defending him and saying that you are
you all are admitted liars you're trying
to exploit him he is no longer with us
you're just opportunistic and trying to
get money from the estate and from
Michael Jackson what do you all say to
that
it's an old argument that they've used
for many you know every time they come
out with that they say it's just about
the money for me the lawsuit was about
fighting back for little James nobody
fought for me as a kid but I'm old
enough now to fight for myself
so win or lose you know that doesn't
matter what matters is fighting and so
this part of my process my healing
process I understand why that's hard for
people to get because it's really
complex emotionally psychologically the
way that this has evolved for me you
know after I fell apart emotionally in
an explicit way with a couple of nervous
breakdowns which led to me disclosing
the abuse for the first time to my
therapist once I began talking about it
after 22 years of silence it initiated
this kind of everything I'd been holding
down for 22 years started coming out of
me right this emotional and mental and
physical upheaval and then some point in
that healing process I would say man I
know maybe nine months or so in what
started arising in me was this question
first how can i how can I take this
thing that happened to me
Michael abusing me this horrible thing
that happened to me that shouldn't have
happened to me that shouldn't happen to
any kid but it did so what can I do with
it now all right how can I take this bad
thing and try and turn it into something
good for other people and for myself so
from that question arose this desire
what how could I tell the truth and
where what platform when I hear you and
you both are saying very similar things
that you want to help others that you
want to shine a light and it sounds very
noble so there is still a potential of
getting money from the Jackson estate
and they're saying that if you didn't
have that looming even as a possibility
in the background you would not be
telling this story so in relation to
that this is all about money is their
bottom line
right especially wait for you all right
in relation to me deciding to do the
court case in the first place it was all
those reasons I spoke of trying to find
a platform but that's the thing trying
to find what is the most powerful
platform to tell my story and the legal
system is what we have right I could
have just you know gone and done
interviews and that sort of thing right
and it most likely would have been
sensationalized and would have been all
the buzz for a couple of weeks or a
month and then it's over and what good
would that have done yeah so it was my
attempt to try and find a platform where
this would be taken seriously so that's
why I chose that platform I understand
that the producer director Dan Reid came
to you you all didn't go to him are you
all getting paid for your participation
in this documentary no we're not getting
paid for the documentary never will
never have no licensing for photos or
for video never have and never will
receive a cent from this documentary
film in any way shape or form you to
James either any money that you did you
get any money for your participation in
this documentary in any way no there's
no there's no money no money in the
future no money now you had a breakdown
as well James yeah it happened I mean I
was in a continuous breakdown it was
it's not a it's not any kind of way to
live but you don't connect something
that happened to you as a kid as the
reason why this is happening until I saw
when Wade came out and he saw interview
was Wade on TV right and it was like oh
my god that's me and okay this is from
abuse didn't reach out to him not
immediately it was it was more like okay
if there's a cause I can find a solution
and so when I first saw it it wasn't an
instant like relief like I was triggered
like seeing you was like coming back
all that sort of fear being caught
wrapped up so was like weeks have just
kind of panic and then that sort of had
to unravel itself and then then the
process of like oh my god now if I'm
gonna fix this I gotta say something and
if I say something I can't go back yeah
and this is the world will know this
isn't like stays in the family
right like the decision to come forward
is scary the thing is you can do where
does Michael Jackson sit with you both
today I don't think I can answer that
it's yeah I still have really I can't
yeah a lot of mixed feelings there's
still there's still a bit of love and
there's still it's almost like a guilt
for saying the truth like a the Traynham
like you betrayed yeah and it's like I
still have those old wiring you know but
still they're so you know my
relationship or my understanding my
relationship with him I think is gonna
it needs a lot of work and when you hear
a Michael Jackson song you think what or
you do it does it is it a trigger for
you yeah yeah it's gotten better for me
but a lot of times if I'm gonna
restaurant or say yes anywhere a lot of
times I'll have to leave cuz I'll just I
feel it in my body first before I even
realize that it's playing they'll start
feeling some anxiety or sometimes even
because his music was such a huge part
of my life I'll be tapping along to the
song or I'll be singing the melody and
then I'll realize what I'm doing and it
kind of takes over my whole body and I
have to leave I think your mothers are
going to be in for some criticism they
are prominently featured in this
documentary and I think as most mothers
looking at this they think what was
wrong with him how could they have allow
that why did they allow it and your
answer do you feel your mothers need to
be defended are you are you okay with
your mothers both of you my yes my
relationship with my mother has
grown immensely over the last six years
or so it was really challenging for a
while and I've gone through many phases
just in this healing process in relation
to how I've gone through lots of anger
towards her lots of confusion thankfully
we've been able to go through a lot of
healing through this process because the
mother's number one job is to protect
her child and as I watched that I had a
lot of questions about how the behavior
of your mother's in particular yeah the
parents are groomed the parents are
groomed the parents are groomed as well
so it's Michael spends a lot of time
talking to your parents and connecting
with them and build a relationship so
it's not they he pays attention to them
and they're groomed over the time so it
is there it is their job to protect us
and they didn't but I try to look at it
from their point of view without letting
them up though I think when you all had
your sons to the difference that that
made for you
wasn't that a life-changing moment for
both of you when you had your sons that
was everything my son being if my if I
never had a son I might still be in
silence really I think there's a really
good chance mm-hmm what I understand
about it now is that I had become so
disconnected from myself as a little boy
over the years in through the process of
kind of pushing all of this down but I
had no I had no relationship with a
little weight I had no kind of concept
or care for in my mind little my son did
you see yourself as when I started
having visions or images of what
happened to me happening to my son and
ice and I saw images of Michael doing it
to my son and that was the first time
that those kind of thoughts in relation
to Michael ever had an extremely
negative scary emotional reaction in me
you know it was once I could see really
understand
this is what a little boy looks like and
feels like and thinks like and behaves
like this is what innocence feels like
that was me the Jackson family points
out to us that your story's changed
after Michael's death is what they're
saying they also believe that if he were
still alive you all would not be sitting
here talking to us right now
there would be no movie there would be
no documentary you would not be talking
what do you say to them and he can't
defend himself of course because he's no
longer here
right other kids have come forward when
he was alive
but they're saying you two in particular
would not be coming out because your
stories have changed you defended him
and now you you're telling a different
story and that if you were alive you
would not be doing that yeah first of
all I mean it's hard to speculate if
Michael was still alive and all of the
other rest of the details of my life
were the same meaning I became a father
right and I went through the same
process that I did of this realization
and going through the healing process my
belief is that we'd still be doing this
of course some details may be different
but what it would be now I'm in the
court case would have been about sending
Michael to jail James I don't I don't
know what I've taken this to my grave I
certainly planned on doing that so the
documentary you said you plan on taking
it to your grave right so I had no
expectations of ever telling anyone so
you know if he if he was still alive
yeah yeah I don't know maybe I would
have taken it to my grave I don't know
do you think that there are others out
there I do think there are others out
there but but I also don't expect them
to just come out now that we're coming
out it's such a difficult thing to do to
come out you have to do it when you're
ready yeah I believe there are many
other boys that Michael abused I find it
hard to believe that he had boys around
for any other reason than to sexually
abuse them
I you know also saw with other boys
Michael doing so many of the same
grooming techniques all the touching and
the kissing and the hugging and the
secrets and the disappearing we'd all be
hanging out and then he would disappear
motherboy off with and go into another
room go behind a closed door disappear
for an hour or so rejoin all these
things that he would do with me when you
were this special one yeah
so I also didn't see you know explicit
abuse happening with another boy but I
believe he abused many other boys we
can't change what happened to us it
happened it's done but what can we do
with it now how can we provide comfort
for other survivors how can we provide
education to move towards prevention
that's what this is about and Michael
just happens to be the guy the abuser in
this child sexual abuse story right